zum ersten mal wieder mehr als 1000
flüchtlinge pro tag und bei der
regierung abwarten schulterzucken ja und
ein foto das das ganz gut symbolisiert
das kommt vom kurfürstendamm von peter
altmaier der ist das shoppen gegangen
beim apple store am kurfürstendamm
ist ja erwischt worden sozusagen in der
schlange stehen total sympathisches foto
er steht da an wie du und ich muss
warten bis er eingelassen wird mit
gebotenen abstand und dann schaut er
sich mal um da drin bei den neuesten
digitalgeräten aber das ist ja noch der
wirtschaftsminister der könnte sich
kümmern um inflation beispielsweise und
genauso geht es wie du gesagt hast bei
so vielen fragen eben auch bei dem
flüchtlingsthema aktuell mehr als 1000
flüchtlinge jeden tag und man hat das
gefühl ist interessiert aber keines
kümmert sich keiner der noch
bundesinnenminister horst seehofer der
war hierbei bild live und hahn hat dazu
doch recht klare worte gefunden
in so wichtigen fragen wie
grenzkontrollen migrationspolitik tritt
jetzt so eine phase ohne große handlung
ein wie sehr schränkt das die kraft des
innenministeriums ein ja sehr stark
darum hoffe ich ja dass die verhandler
jetzt wird der ampelkoalition in der tat
noch im dezember den kanzler wählen dann
stehen in der trotzdem dann zwei monate
in denen im grunde
ist sie recht optimistisch ich rechne
semesters ja bis der kanzler gewählt ist
vielleicht fünf wochen aber wichtig wäre
dass die neue regierung bald zustande
kommt denn gerade in meinem bereich von
der inneren sicherheit bis zur migration
stehen sehr sehr große aufgaben an wir
haben nicht nur klima sondern wir haben
große große nationale und internationale
probleme zu lösen wir hatten vor zwei
tagen zum ersten mal seit vielen jahren
am tag 1 über 1000 zuwanderer wenn sie
erst mal auf den monat hochrechnen dann
wissen sie dass dringender
handlungsbedarf gerechtes mal aufs jahr
hoch sind 300.000 genau diese rechnung
hat horst seehofer der noch
bundesinnenminister eben aufgemacht
zeigen wir noch mal diese seehofer
rechnung also er sagt im moment mehr als
1000 zuwanderer pro tag das rechnen wir
mal hoch also in fünf tagen haben wir
dann schon die größe eines dorfes ab
5000 menschen spricht man ja von einem
dorf oder nochmal weiter einen monat
lang solche zuwanderung dann haben wir
schon eine kleinstadt von etwa 20.000
einwohnern erreicht in drei monaten die
größe einer großstadt erreicht also eine
stadt ab 100000 einwohnern dann das also
ist die aktuelle und tatsächlich
realistische rechnung von
bundesinnenminister horst seehofer zur
aktuellen zuwanderung vor allen dingen
durch gewunken rüber geschickt von
belarus diktator alexander lukaschenko
über polen weiter zu uns nach europa
nach deutschland auch ja die zahl der
zuwanderer nach deutschland und in die
eu wächst also erstmals seit der
flüchtlingskrise 2015 wieder deutlich an
und genau darüber sprechen wir jetzt mit
dem vorsitzenden der
bundespolizeigewerkschaft heiko teggatz
ist uns jetzt zugeschaltet schönen guten
tag guten tag wir bitten sie jetzt
gerade in die nächsten monate
ja mit großer sorge also für mich ist
das mehr als unverständlich dass unsere
bundesregierung jetzt ein stillstand
erreicht hat und diesen stillstand auch
hält sie jetzt ganz dringend
erforderlich entscheidungen zu treffen
und werden eine bundesregierung
geschäftsführend im amt ist dann soll
sie die geschäfte gefälligst auch führen
und entscheidungen treffen ausgeufert
angedeutet 1000 migranten täglich über
unsere grenzen im osten im süden und
auch auf den flughäfen das sind
alarmsignale die darf man keine 14 tage
mehr vor sich herschieben dann werden
wir wieder ein kollaps erleben wir in
2015 an der südgrenze hatten das ist
angst mache sowas sagen einige die im
moment auf solche rechnungen blicken
auch auf die seehofer rechnungen ist das
angstmache wollen auch sie aufschrecken
alarmieren einfach nur nein das ist
keine angst mache das dann harte fakten
und das ministerium selbst operiert ja
mit den zahlen 1000 täglich und die muss
man verdammt noch mal ernst nähmen und
schnell haben
was muss jetzt genau ganz konkret
passieren um die situation in den griff
zu bekommen
also zunächst mal hätte ich mir
gewünscht langsame antwort zu bekommen
auf meinen brief vor 14 tagen an herrn
minister da habe ich die drei konzerten
forderung gestellt ich habe zum einen
gesagt wir müssen temporäre
grenzkontrollen einführen an der grenze
zu polen um kontrolliert die zuwanderung
begleiten zu können zweitens müssen die
fluggesellschaften die dort den
russischen diktator unterstütze und die
menschen nach belarus bringen
sanktioniert werden durch die eu und
drittens bedarf es ein ganz konsequenten
außen grenzschutz an der europäische
union und polen wäre gut beraten sich
dort an der grenze zu bella wo es auch
durch frontex unterstützen zu lassen
sagt der chef der
bundespolizeigewerkschaft heiko teggatz
hierbei bild live danke für das gespräch
und wir gehen dorthin wo die die sich
nach deutschland durchgeschlagen haben
im moment meistens landen nämlich in
eisenhüttenstadt dort sind wir verbunden
mit unserem bild reporter kollegen til
biermann der dort steht an dem zentralen
erstaufnahmelager so heißt es schönen
guten tag auch an dich schilder uns
einmal die situation dort wo also immer
mehr flüchtlinge von weißrussland
durchgewunken bei uns auch ankommen
ja hier in eisenhüttenstadt sind zurzeit
rund 2000 menschen untergebracht die
meisten aus dem irak aus jemen auch aus
dem libanon auch einige aus syrien und
dieses erstaufnahmelager hat eine
kapazität von 4.000 dies also noch nicht
erreicht und ab nächster woche soll das
auch nach frankfurt oder verlegt werden
es ungefähr 20 kilometer von hier da
wird die bundespolizei das ganze
übernehmen ich konnte auch mit ein paar
leuten sprechen die hier aus diesem
erstaufnahmelager kam die sind hier in
quarantäne dürfen aber ab und zu mit
einer maske raus und etwas zu essen
kaufen in dem in den supermärkten in der
umgebung und ja die erzählten haid wie
es war die also die ganze reise von von
der heimat bis hierhin kostet um die
sieben 8000 euro oder ist einmal das
visum drin für bill gross dann ist das
flugticket da drin und dann auch ja dass
das schmuggel durch polen gegen
teilweise zu fuß teilweise lassen sie
sich mit dem auto fahren also die
ärmsten der armen können sich das nicht
leisten ist er ein sehr große
investition auch das ganze
jetzt dort mit den menschen umgegangen
worauf ist man vorbereitet auch
also die haben die sind hier in zelten
untergebracht ich habe mit einem
gesprochen der schon 2014 kam aus syrien
dessen frau jetzt gerade in so einem
zelt ist sie hat er jetzt quasi
nachgeholt geld gespart arbeitet als
gabelstaplerfahrer in berlin hat das
geld zusammengespart um seine frau halt
nachzuholen und der sagt die den geht es
gut die kriegen dort essen ist es warm
genug also die sind so weit zufrieden
wir sind glücklich hier angekommen zu
sein und sagen uns einmal wie groß die
toleranz dort ist der menschen in
eisenhüttenstadt also sagen die sich ach
komm lass die regierung dann noch zwei
drei monate abwarten das gucken wir uns
mal ganz in ruhe an ob das wirklich bei
entsprechenden zahlen weiter bleibt die
nächsten tage die nächsten wochen mehr
als 1000 pro tag eben die da über die
grenze nach europa gucken oder wächst
die anspannung in eisenhüttenstadt
also hier ist es recht entspannt ich
habe auch mit kollegen gesprochen die
hier auch in den letzten tagen viel
waren das ist hier wirklich am rande der
stadt vor mir das sieht jetzt nicht so
ein plattenbaugebiet
ab und zu träufeln hier so ein paar
menschen raus vielleicht mal drei mal
vier also das ist jetzt nicht keine man
kann hier nicht sich von einer groß
angespannten lage sprechen mit den
einwohnern das ist hier scheint mir so
weit alles unter kontrolle
danke biermann für diese information aus
eisenhüttenstadt also dort wo immer mehr
flüchtlinge von weißrussland von belarus
durchgewunken auch bei uns in
deutschland eben landen danke dafür und
wir wollen weiter sprechen hier im
studio mit unserem bild chefreporter
hans jörg vehlewald über dieses große
und zunehmende flüchtlingsproblem wieder
in deutschland und die situation dass
sich offenbar nicht richtig jemand
kümmert der chef der bundespolizei hat
gerade gesagt mensch schreibt briefe ich
schreibe genau was wir brauchen aber es
passiert das problem ist eigentlich
müsste man sich ja da stoppen die
flüchtlinge wo sie beginnen das heißt
herkunftsländern das ist somalia
das ist irak in afghanistan syrien vor
allem dort müsste man endlich eine
aufklärungskampagne machen ihr kommt
hier nicht allzu weit im zweifel werdet
ihr wieder zurückgeschickt ihr müsst
durch gegenden speziell an der polnisch
weißrussischen grenze wo es bitterkalt
ist die machen sich einfach keine
vorstellungen darüber was das indoor
bevorsteht dann müsste man eigentlich
die insbesondere die weißrussen und
dahinter steht auch moskau daran hindern
diese sich als wirklich als schlepper
zurück es wird ja nicht mit sanktionen
wäre das zumindest möglich mehr als
sanktionen hat man da schlicht und
ergreifend nicht möglicherweise wird
auch über diesen g20 gipfel der jetzt am
wochenende stattfindet auch darüber
gesprochen werden im zweifel muss man
sich vielleicht auch geld zahlen ich
weiß nicht was da an diplomatischen
möglichkeiten ist sicher ist nur die
leute die jetzt hier in eisenhüttenstadt
ankommen die haben schon einen derartig
schrecklichen weg hinter sich das geht
zunächst über die flügel aus afrika aus
beirut bis nach minsk und von dort dann
wirklich mit bussen organisiert durch
lukas schenk und dem präsidenten von
weißrussland bis an die grenze und da
werden sie dann sich selbst überlassen
ich habe selbst vor ort dort an der an
der grenze polen weißrussland
flüchtlingslager gesehen die waren
inzwischen verlassen dort hatten sie
sich umgezogen hatten tatsächlich
schlafsäcke zb mit belarussische
aufschrift griechischen buchstaben minus
zehn grad stand auch darauf die hatten
also durchaus ihre ausrüstung auf
weißrussische seite bekommen um dann
rüber zu gehen und werden dann im tiefen
urwald das ist ein naturpark der dort
liegt in den wald gelassen und werden
dann eben vom polnischen grenzsoldaten
aufgegriffen und was da passiert
momentan an der grenze das ist zwar sehr
hart man sicherlich auch im sinne der eu
nämlich dort eine klare linie zu ziehen
ihr könnt hier nicht einfach rein
gleichzeitig werden die leute aber
wirklich in grauenhaften zustand aus
kuchen hat durch durchgefroren wieder
einfach im wald ausgesetzt geht zurück
nach belarus auf der russischen seite
wird wieder zurückgeschickt
kommt hier nicht rein die werden also in
diesen wäldern hin und her geschoben
sind grauenhafte bilder die man bis
dorthin geister ist es angesprochen als
reporter vor ort ein bild von der
situation gemacht und hass berichtet
dazu auf menschen getroffen dass die
hier seit tagen nur aus pfützen trinken
können weil sie nichts haben als dass es
das was sie am leibe tragen und zum
spielball jetzt werden zur politik ist
wird mit falschen chancen gelockt sie
sind verwickelt eigentlich opfer eines
politischen konflikts und gehen mit
ihrer eigenen menschlichen hoffnung
dorthin wie begegnen dir diese menschen
dort wenn es dann heißt jetzt müsst ihr
wieder zurück sie aber auf
weißrussischer seite sowie hoffnung
bekommen haben den wurde ja das gelobte
land versprochen jetzt geht nur über und
dann heißt es aber dort das war alles
eine lüge von der anträge standen davor
sieben so marlies die als durch afrika
geflogen sind dann über istanbul nach
mainz geflogen sind und bis dahin
gelandet waren die hatten inzwischen 14
tag 15 tage im wald und hinter sich bei
minusgraden in der nacht hatten nicht
mal mehr schuhe an die waren durch
geschlossen die scheibe ging barfuß die
füßen mussten behandelt werden jahren so
dick und angeschwollen und entzündet
dass auch die dicksten stiefel nicht
mehr passten sanitäter haben ihnen dann
versucht diese schuhe anzuziehen die
sind dann tatsächlich zu fuß trotzdem
weiter gegangen weil ihnen kein keine
schuhe mehr passt wir sind vollkommen
ausgehungert wir sagten wir hatten seit
vier tagen nichts mehr zu essen in dem
stück gab es nicht mal so die maisfelder
die dort sonst noch herum stehen die
sind inzwischen abgeerntet das heißt
auch nicht mal mehr maiskolben zu essen
wir haben wirklich das was ihn gegeben
wurde regelrecht verschlungen gerade
einen 16-jährigen der schob sich gleich
drei eier nacheinander in den mond
während so ausgehungert war es eine
furchtbare bilder sind auch schwer
verletzte dabei einen syrer dem wir
begegnet sind bei dem war ein baum im
wald ein baum auf den auf den brustkorb
gefallen der schrie vor schmerzen und
wurde trotzdem wir bei den erfahren
haben am nächsten tag einfach wieder
zurückgeschoben auf belarussische sein
eine neue flüchtlingskrise ein
flüchtlingsdrama dass sich hier
ja nur wenige hundert kilometer entfernt
von berlin gerade abspielt in europa und
das natürlich das haben wir gerade von
till aus eisenhüttenstadt gehört immer
weiter zu uns nach deutschland auch
drängt dazu unser bild chefreporter hans
jörg vehlewald vielen dank für deinen
besuch